the loud house was crowned as
Nickelodeon's top show of 2016 beating
popular shows like paw Patrol Henry
danger and Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
the loud house revolves around the
chaotic lives of a family with eleven
kids whose names all begin with the
letter L and their friends just wait
until the end to see if your favorite
character is part of our list don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a thumbs up today we're
talking about ten the loud house
characters in real life Lisa let's just
jump right into it and start with the
second youngest of the loud family Lisa
is just four years old but she's not
your typical toddler despite her age she
is one of the smartest people in her
family and she already won a Nobel Prize
for her outstanding accomplishments but
although she's incredibly intelligent
Lisa still has childlike qualities she's
often sarcastic she rarely smiles when
she speaks with a cute list she wants to
become a scientist and through most of
the episodes she can be seen working on
various experiments although it seems
ridiculous for a four-year-old Lisa
loves solving difficult math problems
and she sometimes studies her siblings
bathroom habits lisa has short brown
hair big round glasses and she usually
wears a green sweater with purplish
pants
check out tumblr user lumple Stiltskin
who decided to dress up as Lisa chica
passes this nobel-prize-winning
four-year-old in real life lisa is
played by Lara Jill Miller
known for giving a voice to characters
in several cartoons including Henry
hugglemonster and Curious George
and Emmy winning cartoon did you know
that Lisa along with her other sisters
was named after the loud house directors
actual sisters he first created the
characters as rabbits with names
starting with being we're so glad he
recreated them as humans and
lissa her no-nonsense personality Lola
Lola is the third youngest child from
the loud family she's six years old and
she's what you'd call a total diva we
have a perfect celebrity that matches
Lola's look and we'll reveal who it is
in a couple of seconds but first let's
talk about Lola this six year old loves
to look at herself in a mirror she loves
anything that's girly and she can be
quite bratty like most six year olds
Lola comes with a temper and you don't
want to get on her bad side
she has long blonde hair and she usually
wears a long pink dress as she's still a
child
she's also missing her two front teeth
which only makes her look even crazier
whenever she throws a tantrum she loves
getting her way and she's by far one of
the brightest characters on the show do
you remember
Elena Thompson from here comes honey boo
boo we think she's a perfect real-life
version of Lola especially if you watch
her episodes in toddlers and tiaras
Lola's voice belongs to Grady Lyle who
you might know from playing Mandy in the
grim adventures of Billy and Mandy and
Frankie in Foster's Home for Imaginary
Friends along with having a sister named
Lola the creator of the loud house also
had a wiener dog called Lola which is
how this bratty character got her name
we can't wait to see what Lola will be
up to in the next episodes Lana next in
line is Lana loud Lola's twin Lana is
Lola's complete opposite
while Lola loves to wear dresses and put
on makeup
Lana prefers doing tomboyish things
which include playing in the mud
although physical looks are identical to
Lola's Lana has a completely different
style she often wears a red snapback and
denim overalls just like Lola she also
has two missing front teeth and long
blonde hair that's usually put in low
pigtails have you ever seen the fourth
season of MasterChef junior we think
that the nine-year-old Addison Smith
looks like a perfect version of Lana
she's often seen wearing colored
snapback and has blonde hair although we
can imagine
is nowhere near as wild as Lana we can
definitely see the resemblance with
these two Lana is also voiced by the
very talented gray de lisle who gave
Lana her iconic and slightly raspy child
voice the director of the loud house
said the inspiration for Lana's
character and all other sisters came
from his own ten siblings family
although Lana is highlighted as someone
who loves playing in the mud and getting
her hands dirty his siblings never
complained about how their characters
were portrayed Kris said it's because
they have a fantastic sense of humor
just like the characters from the loud
family Lucy
most of us have gone through a goth
phase as teenagers do you remember that
look we were all dark clothing had a
thick black eyeliner we listened to sad
music we were incredibly moody it looks
like Lucy the eight year old is also in
that phase she's just two years older
than Lola and Lana but three years
younger than Lincoln which makes her the
only one with such a big age gap you
probably noticed by now that everyone in
the family has a specific personality
that makes them stand out from the
others
Lucy is the goth child Lucy is a pale
skinned character who's always wearing
an all-black outfit her black
shoulder-length hair sports bangs almost
cover up her eyes she's mysterious she
always has a frown and she loves scaring
people
she moves silently and she's often seen
startling her family as she appears out
of nowhere she's definitely a fun
character to cosplay and low-key fan 18
from deviantART decided to show what
Lucy would look like in real life she
really nailed her character and her
bangs are absolutely perfect
Lucy's voice belongs to Jessica DeCicco
who you might know from series like
Adventure Time and DC superhero girls we
love Lucy for her unique personality
even though she doesn't play a very
excitable or a happy character she
stands out from the rest of her family
and it's why we love her Lincoln along
with Lucy the 11 year old Lincoln is the
only character in the loud
that doesn't have the typical brown or
blonde hair Lincoln is the family's
middle child but he's also the only boy
can you imagine being the only boy in a
family with ten sisters is probably why
he and Lucy are one of the quietest ones
in the family
Lincoln is slim and has unique white
hair that makes him stand out from the
rest
much like the four year old Lisa Lincoln
is the nerd of the family although he
doesn't have a Nobel Prize Lincoln is
one of those kids that loves reading
comic books and playing video games as
the only boy in the family
Lincoln is often being taken advantage
of by his sisters and has to put up with
participating in fashion shows and other
experiments you think that would make
him Rebell against his sisters but
Lincoln is a pretty quiet kid we think
that the model Paul Craddock could
easily pass as a real-life Lincoln did
you know that Lincoln is voiced by two
child actors both grant Palmer and Colin
Dean are absolutely adorable and they
did an outstanding job portraying
Lincoln Lincoln actually looks exactly
like the rabbit from the original loud
house characters all the creator had to
do was erase his triangle nose rabbit
ears and the tail
that explains why Lincoln has his white
hair Flynn let's move on to the 13 year
old Lynne loud the fifth oldest child
and one of the most competitive members
of the loud family as you can guess from
her clothing Lynne loves sports and she
always wants to be the number one she
turns everything into a competition
which as you can imagine can easily get
on her siblings nerves
if Lisa got a Nobel Prize it's safe to
say Lynne will easily compete at the
Olympics Lynne often wears an athletic
outfit and she sports brown hair tied in
a ponytail we think that Anna Romero a
Spanish football enthusiast could easily
portray Lynne in
action-movie although she'll have to
love more than just football because Lin
excels at just about any sport have you
ever wondered why her voice sounds
similar to the voice of her
eight-year-old sister her character is
voiced by Jessica DeCicco who also gives
voice to Lucy you've probably guessed by
now that Lynne is not the one that's
easily mess with as she's the most
competitive she's also the most
confrontational you wouldn't want to get
on a bad side
the creator of the show mentioned that
if he was a storyboard artist he'd
easily focus on just Lincoln and Lynn as
his two main characters but instead he's
giving everyone a chance to shine
Louanne Louanne loud is 14 years old and
she's one of our favorite members of the
loud family
she loves to joke around and she's what
we call a queen of puns although most of
her jokes usually fall flat with the
crowd we can't help but love her
slightly outrageous pranks which can
sometimes go to the next level on April
Fool she pranked the entire household by
placing traps in every corner but LuAnn
is also good at looking at the bright
side of life and seeing everything as a
positive experience and that's precisely
why we love her she usually wears a
white top with a flower on the front
collar and a yellow plated skirt she has
brown hair that's usually tied up in a
ponytail and she's also seen wearing
braces LuAnn is voiced by Christina
Pacelli who played Catwoman and Miss
Martian in DC's superhero girls and gave
her voice to several other cartoon
characters a deviantART cosplayer called
the O one angel decided to dress up as
Luanne and she managed to recreate a
pretty good real-life version of the 13
year old jokester of the loud family all
she needs now is a handful of puns some
pranks under her sleeve and a lifetime
supply of bad jokes Lennie
unfortunately we haven't got the time to
talk about the rock chick Luna so let's
just skip to the second oldest character
of the LA
family Lenny is a typical 16 year old
Lenny is known as the dizziest member of
the family she's also the most gullible
and naive and is often an easy target
for others even though she has to cope
with 10 siblings Lenny has a heart of
gold and his kind and compassionate she
has long blonde hair and is wearing a
teal colored dress with the same colored
slippers don't you think that julianne
hough looks like the perfect real-life
version of Lenny although it looks like
Lenny's the second oldest and least
intelligent person in the family she is
quite creative and loves fashion design
finally her four year old sister Lisa is
the second youngest but she's the
smartest of the bunch Lenny is voiced by
Liliana Mooney who you might know from
Howl's Moving Castle and Cheaper by the
Dozen unlike many other voice actors on
the show Liliana only voices Lenny which
is why the character can stand out from
the rest
sure you might get frustrated with Lenny
because she's so naive but you can't say
she's not an excellent addition to the
loud family it's definitely hard being a
big sister to that many siblings but no
one knows this better than the oldest
loud character Laurie Laurie loud is
your typical 17 year old although she
and Lenny are quite similar in age her
characters are completely different as
the oldest of the bunch
Laurie uses that power to control her
siblings and make them do whatever she
wants she's bossy and her temper is
quite similar to Lois as a big sister
she's also protective and knows when to
stand up for her younger siblings much
like Lenny Laurie has long blonde hair
she's usually seen in shorts and a tank
top and she always has a phone attached
to her hands we told you she's your
typical 17 year old it's not easy being
a big sister of that many siblings but
Laurie somehow makes it work with her
ongoing dominance as a firstborn child
really who can blame her if you're
looking for a real-life version of
Laurie
you might want to check out Emma Stone
as a blonde
doesn't she look perfect Laurie is
voiced by Catherine Taber who gave her
voice to several side cartoon characters
and we love that she's able to play the
oldest sibling of the loud family
we can't imagine what it must be like to
have a family this big but we also can't
imagine what it must be like to be our
next character who has a huge crush on
Laurie
Clyde we've shown you 9 out of 11
characters from the loud family with the
loud siblings also have best friends and
one of them is Clyde who hangs out with
Lincoln as an only child Clyde's
extremely jealous of Lincoln's large
family and as we mentioned he's an
uncontrollable crush on Laurie who
unfortunately has a boyfriend
even though Clyde is just 11 years old
he's incredibly romantic and wants to
treat Laurie like the princess she is at
the same time
Clyde loves to hang out with his best
friend play video games and read comics
Clyde's obsession with Laurie reminds us
of Helga's obsession with Arnold in Hey
Arnold it makes us wonder if he'll ever
succeed in his mission to make Laurie
his girlfriend
Clyde sports an afro haircut and he's
usually seen wearing glasses a shirt
pants and trainers check out this cutie
he could easily be Clyde's real-life
twin Clyde is voiced by Kahlil Harris
who also voiced a Jay in blaze on the
monster machines we can't wait to see
what's next for this 11 year old
we really hope his dreams of making
Laurie his girlfriend comes true we're
all cheering you on Clyde are you quiet
or are you the loudest in your family
let us know in the comments for more
videos like this one check out 10 kids
who look like cartoon characters thanks
for watching
[Music]